I'm doing well happy to be you know his
actors like we are there's there's one
thing that we actually have zero
experience with and that's animation not
magic mine no way it was a little
animated you uh you you affected old
generation of men got them quite
animated with you're working vertigo
yeah and here's something that down I
really love about animations
it's whatever they dream up and they
just draw there's no limits there's no
boundaries total freedom absolutely
anything goes yeah well they work with
unshackled Minds something they they've
got so much freedom pure creativity
incredible writing yeah yeah yeah I
gotta take a minute just to say that I'm
really glad to be here it's been a long
time
[Music]
I'm glad to be Lincoln Academy tonight
but my main reason to be a knight is
fear with you and to announce the
nominees for the best animated short
film barrel Daniel Sousa and Dan Goldin
get a horse barn McMullen and Dorothy
McKeon mr. Hublot barn vietze
and Alexandra ESPA goddess possessions
Shuhei Morita room on the broom of max
Lang and yang black our and the Oscar
goes to mr. who blow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the
for Long Beach and Alex on SP gardener
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry a lot of emotion I have to take a
paper Thank You the Academy for this
award thank you for supporting shorts
and new talents it's my first movie as
director and producer the first movie
have Alexander as co-director I feel
it's an American dream thank you is
definitely your photon stick fantastic
future and outwork you deserve an Oscar
my friend Thank You Mikhail Pascal
Davichi we get Lilou and the rest of the
team they work with patient many thanks
to film film Luxembourg G here the
sensational Anne and Artie thank you to
my family and especially Audrey and my
children children's thank you I love you
and finally thank you mr. Hulu for
making this dream become reality
thank you very much mercy
[Applause]